welcome to the dark forest checking your
pals were there for for us shameless
confession about our obsession will make
us laugh and smile so let's explore the
dark forest hello and welcome to the
dork forest I'm Jackie Kashian i'm your
host of the dork forest you know the
websites Jackie Kashian calm dork for
asst comm the dork 4s calm if you love a
determiner and who doesn't family pet
ancestry just takes you to Jackie
Kashian calm and the website is new
Vilmos just revamped it I think you
redid the store page as well it's hard I
guess on mobile to make it all work
right because I have a shitload of merch
so I'm Jackie Kashian calm so if you're
looking at it any phone it takes you to
sort of a flash page that you gotta head
back to whatever see the tour dates and
whatever but dork forest let's do the
credits like Rick Berg composed and sang
that song you just heard he sang it with
his wife Sarah Cohen he will sing again
words he wrote to the Mexican Hat dance
at the end of the program Patrick
Brady's gonna fix this audio and I think
we just said Vilmos does my website
things to do on the Internet yes you the
dork forest is on dork for Escom of
course it's on all things comedy calm
it's on stitcher probably it's on
soundcloud you can listen to it in a
myriad of different ways including
itunes you can leave reviews on iTunes
you can I read them I and then you could
email me Jackie at Jackie Kashian calm
always and I will always respond to your
emails though I won't always read them
aloud because my dork addendums way
behind because i have another podcast
with Laurie Kilmartin and I'm on the
road a lot doing stand-up comedy if you
want a ranger the dork fours t-shirt or
you want just a dork forest t-shirt
those are available on Jackie Kashian
com they're 100-percent cotton union
made here in the United States of
America the prices include shipping nat
nationally and internationally and you
could also get there a stand-up comedy
t-shirt that I sell called spooky
reading girl you can get my CDs or DVD
there is a link to my DVD which is
available streaming from comedy film
nerds com from there downloadable and
then you can always go to amazon or
itunes and by my cds uh just for
downloadable streaming and other than
that you could just listen to my CDs and
DVDs you could just listen to my CDs on
Pandora and Spotify I get a little bit
of a kick back speaking of kickback if
you want to support the show you can use
the donation button it is under the
support the show menu now so it takes
you right there there's both the amazon
banner and the paypal support the show
button paypal is just a direct donation
to the show if you love the show and you
want to support i would love to be
supported and i appreciate any donations
that you give because it helps other
than that there's an amazon banner
doesn't cost you anything all it is is a
portal to amazon you order like normal
at amazon and the dark forest gets a
little bit of a kick back so i would
appreciate that if that's something you
want to do and you can come and see me
do stand-up county my tour schedule is
on my website this week I am going to
toronto for a long time doing the Just
for Laughs comedy festival just for
laughs 42 is what it's called I'm one of
the 42 performers getting to do an
hour-long show and I'm also opening up
for Maria on her hour-long show she's
going to open up on one of my shows
hour-long show and I want her to close
it with her dropping the mic going
follow that [ __ ] anyway so
there's swearing on this show other than
that I think I've said all the things
that need to be said and let's get into
the show already hey it's Jackie Kashian
I'm in my living room at the dork forest
and i'm sitting here with friend of the
show and I'm afraid of his show Graham
Elwood of comedy film nerd hello anyell
a podcast festival that's right how the
hell are you I'm good ya been this is my
haddon all day I'm haddon all day I did
a podcast Kristen Chris Mancini myself
did a call in podcast with the of comedy
film nerd now a new show this guy baz
routan who's an ex UFC fighter
was in the movie um excuse me the big
boom with Kevin James okay um and he
like is an announcer for the UFC's very
fun Greg you see being a hitting thing
what is the hitting think yes
occasionally United fighting company
what is it you have seen is the United
fighting company I may have these fun
little contests in the United fighting
company they get together yeah it's fun
it's a company party yes I gay sell
cupcakes and just to raise money for the
fighting company and then because what
does it stand falls amid fighting
championship it okay not underwear
nothing no focus there in the in their
underwear underwear not useless no it's
underwear [ __ ] chopped you up showing
underwear [ __ ] chopped challenge but P
know Lipsy tight clothes exactly long
time meeting each other so which I like
do you like do you enjoy UFC yes but
fighting I think if the UFC would have
been this popular or even been around
when I was like in high school yeah I
would have done this oh that's what that
would have been your thang I would have
been I played football but I would have
been like now I'm getting in a cage and
aren't you don't you sort a yoga fight
aren't you some sort of hippie jock guy
it's amazing grams yoga fight I don't
you put on yoga pants and I do i do all
that i do yo guys study martial arts
that's it Marshall it is a martial art
that you study but it's less it's more
defensive martial art is it not well
I've studied just the flat-out fighty
ones I and I've done the samurai sword
which is more of a Zen thing and I take
yoga i find you know what as I joke
about that I have at least three friends
who collects wards and and I forget
about you I got at least four friends
that's right side words would grab on
that list uh yeah I started doing the
thing of my aggravation guys say I'm a
hippie trapped in a meat heads body and
very conflicted I'm very
like oh [ __ ] I forgot so is it a crime
Elwood on twitter at Grandma went on
Twitter at grandma went on instagram
instagram i'm on the facebook and grunt
on facebook how about snaps you doing
the snaps i'm john the snaps snap chats
where I'm hiding man that's where am I
it's fantastic when my brother joined
Instagram I was like oh I'm out and so I
know I got a nice on Twitter and I like
I don't want her reading I know she's 16
or 17 so she's fine he's heard but I
don't want to hear uncle Graham uncle
great like Trump to go [ __ ] himself or
whatever oh I do picking it I think I
think that that's needed to tell your
niece I had no online is picking a fight
with the NRA I challenged the whole NRA
to fight me with their fists cuz i said
guns were for [ __ ] oh that's it that
isn't came out none of them came out
that's how they that's how they roll
yeah as the as i said in the dark knight
graphic novel from the 80s it's the
coward's weapon well Batman would know
he's got throwing stars um so smoke bomb
get smoke bombs those are the you know
those are those are the weapons of a guy
with a deep deep pocket that's right sir
those the rivers the weapons of that guy
this world is so lucky I never became a
billionaire right it just imagine your
Batman story man would have been I would
be solving crime right and or left
there'd be no Jerry Sandusky trial baby
is that that guy from penn state of yeah
it's okay hurt raped them yes that's
Jerry Sandusky well I couldn't remember
exactly what he had done to them so I
was like did he rape him or kill him I
couldn't remember and I'll just the rape
he was a football guy right yeah and
guys and Joe Paterno and other people at
the school knew about it for about you
know 13 14 years and did nothing cuz it
would have [ __ ] up the football
program grandma wood stork to miss
injustice you guys yep it's a high
school football but i'm done with the
NFL so suck it oh cuz of the guy who
wouldn't stand for the no I know that's
why all gotta burrows guy
Jesus I'm sitting as Jersey artfire this
is for my uncle who fought in on Iwo
Jima yeah no no not those guys the other
guy it's the Oh God where do you start
with the NFL right with the raping and
the looting ollege odd it's pretty bad
it's pretty bad so they didn't give a
[ __ ] about domestic violence until it's
on video then we're gonna try and do
something about it right and the fact
that they're killing each other's brains
that's that's what led that's what left
me kind of in the dust about it I was
like oh wait we're paying these guys a
lot of money so that we can really
developmentally disabled them right and
we're watch and the NFL knew about CTE
and covered it up set the concussion
esta yeah that's a concussion thing and
they don't want to you know that guys
that gave their literally gave their
bodies and their lives to the game
they're just like I'm sorry yeah right
no benefits for you right you know what
the the Navy takes responsibility for
ALS for Lou Gehrig's disease Wow yeah my
father-in-law passed away from that and
he was in the Navy and he went to the VA
and the VA was like yeah we're we're
just taking credit for that we know that
we you were probably sitting on top of
some napalm or something everyone going
and so we'll just pay for it so if the
Navy can take you know some obscure
disease and be in charge you know say
yeah yeah we're going to cover you how
about the NFL which has a gajillion
dollars ilion dollars and then it's like
you know the TV commercials so I'm a
vegetarian and I don't drink right and I
don't drive a pickup so there's no
advertising for me at all when I
watching ladies though I do like the
gals so here a gal dancing around of
junk and steak pick up you're not your
gun is uh right you're not completely
against all the things no but it is not
enough but why but why aren't there
harvesting like tomatoes yeah yeah
that's it like hey ready for a salad
exactly let's get with some quinoa get a
salad and your hybrid um exactly anyway
that's my I don't know I I wanted a
little bit of a rage right right but
then well fair enough it's a so you did
that podcast and then you did Pardo's
podcast everybody not funny on the I
guess is the players club is sort of a
uh behind the firewall of monies yes and
okay the money firewall right right so I
just did the players club never not
funny 19f was the episode number and
tied half as in fighting as enjoyable as
part of the fighting cousin underwear
fighting when did you and they is that
gonna come out before the LA pod fetish
yes because you're mean you and Chris
found and and Andy would and a Dave
Anthony founded the LA pod fest and yeah
so I love it it's a blast Andy what is
no longer with the festival he got too
busy doing other things but no you
killed yeah we did I had breakfast with
him the other day I know what happened
you know nothing it is buried in a
desert he's buried in a desert he was
having a mimosa so I think things are
working out for me it'll be fine he's
doing good yeah but I remember you guys
all from the get-go mounted that thing
it was Dave Anthony it was idea he came
to chris and i & R ok so this is our
fifth year oh okay sep tember 23 to the
25th um you've done it in the past this
year you're you're busy you're busy
pants on the road tell them fancy man
jokes toasted to to other folks uh yeah
I told Chris a giddy as soon as you find
out the day don't block it out because
there's nothing you know we're here we
are on a podcast so I think we both know
that podcast listeners are awesome and
if anybody's willing to do a destination
podcast festival there a serious fan
they want to hang out they are genuinely
interested in going and getting some
chicken fingers in a Hilton or whatever
was sofitel hotel yeah yeah don't Yeah
over in Beverly Center kind of beverly
center area well last year remember that
was here I told with my car coming back
I know you had to see it a couple of
slasher I was bad day he fell off the
stage like you the same day I did six
pod cantore 25 podcasts in the stand-up
show I wanted to put you in one of those
dog attack suits just so you a cone of
shame yeah he called out just so you
didn't get hurt i knows worried i did
Paul Gill Martin's podcast that day I
did Doug's eating one that's the one
where I fell off the stage him and Karen
yeah and then I did um yeah I didn't one
of mine dork forest that's
we're on and then so that's only three
felt like six no and then I did the
stand up so I think I was just there all
day cuz I wanted to come back and see
the movie earbuds right cuz you shot
that over a course of a year and a half
or whatever and then it took another two
dead and he shot it in this backyard all
right cuz I'm in it you're in it I
didn't get to see it because the next
morning I was too scared to drive cuz I
had totaled my car the night of and so
it any was like we got to get back in
the car do you I mean you can uber if
you want to but I'm saying take my car
and I was like you'd let me take your
car and he goes I think you should get
back and start driving as soon as
possible so you don't freak out about
driving and it was a couple of weeks of
me being shaky about it sure engine yeah
after you hit something yeah and turns
out it might have been my fault there
was a recreation with some business
cards and some and he was like oh that
looks like you that looks like I'll you
um we still haven't talked about your
door to know ten minutes in but that's
fine we talked about the pod fest and
we've talked about so when did you when
did you get into swords let's I let's do
a call back to swords first well I
started studying martial arts for real
like seriously i did a little in college
but i really started getting two in 2004
and the marshal at school I was going to
Jerri blanks martial arts studio Pacific
Palisades they started to have samurai
class there okay and it was taught by
this man Master shimabukuro who was like
one of the better swordsman on the face
of the earth I don't wanna book out
called flashing steel flashing steel
yeah that's a great astok it's fantastic
the first half of the book is all
history and philosophy it's great about
about Tamara yeah oh that sounds amazing
living the samurai code and victory
comes with the sword still in the
scabbard and how do you go and and and
so most of the people in the samurai
class were people that had already
studied other martial arts and so like
everyone and I was the only guy in one
of the only guys in the class that only
had one black belt like everybody else
had all these black belts with all these
other styles so it really attracted like
people that were really into martial
arts okay so I studying regular karate
which is just like you know practical
fighting and stuff like that respond and
learn some weapons nunchucks and the leg
up the sigh and the bow and then I
decide sigh is the Electra ISM it's like
the pitchfork thing oh okay oh the
uneven ditch work thing yeah yeah there
you go yeah mmm so I started going to
that class and I just really loved it
it's very much a more of a Zen thing and
it's about you know beat you got to be
real methodical and everyone's I go with
there's no point when would you use
those there's no product to application
well first of all zombie apocalypse your
guns gonna reload my blade will not need
to be David Wright I can find a
whetstone to sharpen it yes it'll be fun
weapon maintenance you're cleaning your
your gun between combat sessions is when
I would keep my sword polished and sake
um and so did they did you get a sword
when you joined or they give you wooden
swords to start with her he's charged
with wooden swords they don't just like
here's the best players of the pointy
yeah sharp thing the sharpest thing on
the face of the earth alright so yeah
you start with a wooden one and you it's
it's so detailed it's so intricate your
hand all this stuff and um I really the
first like class I really did I was like
I feel like I've been looking for this
my whole life right and you know cuz it
is is it deliberate it feels like one of
those those kind of studies were you
have to make sure like you move in a
specific way and you're holding it right
and hold it there for a second and then
sort sort of like yoga poses but not
right it's so deliberate like that's the
best word I mean it is very specific and
the teachers are not in a bad way but
they're very critical of like it you
know they would should do it right
exactly i'd like you that's a half inch
off Oh like that so you really and I
really I gravitated to that and I was
training with you know he his dojo was
in San Diego so he'd come up and train
with us once a month
okay we train once a week so and then he
got sick and passed away and it was it
was it was so how long did it did you
get to train with him just only about 18
months okay and but the thing I learned
you know was I could I was part of me is
like man I wanted to train me this guy
forever and go study in Japan and all
this but one of the philosophies you
sort of learned is that you know you
sort of stay in the moment and I was
blessed I got to train with this guy for
18 months yes and when are you ever
going to train with a master at anything
a master anybody anybody now like a true
master like he you know could call the
Emperor of Japan that guy would take his
gun yeah he was so it was he just had
was a spectacular person in his
philosophy the way he he just had one
those guys the way he carried himself
the way he entered a room you're just
like wow and not in and not Anna like oh
I'm gonna whoop your ass but just he had
just a presence about him right it
wasn't cocky sort of uh I'm clearly good
at something yeah that kind of thing but
but not but not without humility not
without opportunity yeah and and you
know in his book he he talks about you
even says like so what's the point of
this we no one's gonna walk down the
street and get into a sword fight so
right why would you do this and he can't
openly carry your sword hot [ __ ] log
in to change make America great so uh so
I one of the things he had in there was
like so what is the point of this well
he's talked about like it was all about
the samurai code was all about honor
right and and living a life of honor and
dying with honor and it wasn't that
samurais you know had a death wish right
it was that they you know everybody
knows they're gonna die they wanted to
live a purpose a life of purpose okay
I'm a life of service the word samurai
literally means to serve okay so it was
about um well that's kind of neat it's
great yeah and we have some use and and
to give back to others that's ideal and
also to be able to sort so it was sort
of like they train themselves to be the
perfect weapon and then hopefully never
had
use it okay because once you've drew the
sword mm-hmm is kind of game on you know
you were risking your life to that's the
other thing that's why I say the gun is
the coward's weapon because I could just
shoot someone and there's no
repercussions where if Anna fistfight or
even a sword battle right I'm risking my
own body as well so I better be it damn
near needs to be the last resort it has
to be important it is to be important if
we're gonna fight each other ya like
like children yeah essentially like
scrabbling around in the dirt like
animals I'm gonna have hurt both of us
right a gun with the ranged weapon yes
is I see why they might think that
that's just pointless it's know right I
mean I get yeah so um one of the things
he talked about in his book flashing
steel was like so in today's world
you're not going to get into a sword
battle but let's say you're having a
business disagreement with somebody how
can you resolve that with both of you
keeping your honor okay so how can we
come to a resolution because if I oh
that sounds incredibly Japanese yes
exactly and it's like so if I just like
whatever you and I are arguing and I
just steamroll over you and I quote
unquote get my way you're not gonna like
me you're not gonna respect me you're
not gonna want to do business with me
again may be right but if we come to a
conclusion where we both go okay that's
cool I get that you know I okay I agree
with you or you know or I don't agree
with you but you have made your point
yeah we're gonna I respect it I respect
your opinion yeah we don't have to agree
that's cool so those are that's where
like the victory comes with the sword
still in the scabbard and it is really
pissed off how can you defuse the
situation without acquiescing to them
right not losing your honor right well
end with also all without taking theirs
how does that how does that manifest
itself when you're when you're just
studying with the sword is there is
there like a lecture series it goes
along with through outta there is the I
mean honestly bitching this book is how
do you pronounce this name Ian
shimabukuro XI mu boo crew and it's
flashing steel flashing a steal okay
yeah so um because
it so precise and there's so much
repetition mm-hmm that's sort of he goes
what you should be training as you're
not cutting someone down you're cutting
down your own ego you're cutting down
your sort of defects of character your
you know all i'm impatient or i might
fly off the handle or are oh so it's a
it's it's an example of how to learn to
do things patiently and correctly the
first time and and yeah and the practice
sort of a meditation II kind of thing
very much so part of it is to he said
you know if you make a mistake because
they're they're called Wasa's which is
like a form like you've seen them in
many martial arts and karate they're
called Coty's okay it's like a it's like
a series of moves together and it has a
specific name and you do these specific
moves together okay so when you perform
in these wazos or what they call bata
hose by jose are also sort of cop more
combat applicable okay where the Oise
azure some of them are more sort of
their the art part of martial arts okay
anyone show like style has this right
it's it's sort of what their forms and
you have to do it in front of judges and
then they give you a belt that's part of
it yeah sometimes sometimes yeah yeah so
as you go that's not the point of it but
I mean that's that's how I'm it's
beneficial when I have been in a
conference room or possibly a large
gymnasium and I'm watching a child and
they're doing forms right but yeah that
is so that is part of usually the
testing in any martial arts style you do
the forms right and then you would
probably spar and you know do all the
sort of stuff so like sparring is like
the practical application right whereas
the forms is sort of the art part of
martial arts okay so when we practice
these losses and then we did kind of a
form of sparring with the wooden sticks
mmm where you're you're throwing it's
sort as your sword fighting so you're
blocking you're countering and stuff
like that but again so in the wazza like
if you make a mistake one things he
talks about the samurai so come on
dammit yeah you keep going right okay I
made a mistake i'm gonna keep calling
and and right you don't wallow in it
even for it as if you can just not even
wallow for a heartbeat that'll be great
because it stops from moment
yeah it stops your momentum like if you
have a problem with someone you saw you
resolve it with that person privately
you don't go into a big thing with
everybody else right so it's it's it was
it's really it was really fascinating
studying with him and you know I'd love
to find another school because I'm not
level or some at that level because i
missed it when he passed away and the
guys that are still in my class they're
very competent swordsman they're they're
good but it's it's different it's it's
not slam on them and we all felt it we
all missed him there was this huge void
you know and so you know I've been
looking i went to i sat in last year at
dana and santo he studied with bruce lee
ok at his school and the marina its god
it's awesome but it's so expensive well
that's the other thing too is that is is
to find someone that gifted or that
talented it's it's got to be expensive
to take those classes right it's so
expensive so i mean i found i saw the
seasons of dollars original hundred
bucks a week what do we talk it's a
couple you know it depends it's a
hundred to it's between like one and two
or three hundred bucks a month oh wow
okay starts to add up it does add up
especially if it's only one class a week
it's some of them have more classes i
mean your signals different or whatever
so it's it's it's I I but it's a
commitment it's financially and I mean
you want it to be a bank you wanted to
be an emotional commitment or my
physical commitment but you also then
have to have the time the last two years
I haven't done much martial arts cuz
I've been focusing so much on getting
earbuds done bring is why I had the time
or the money right do it and I really
sort of miss it I think that's sort of
my vision of what the last part of my
life would be is just sort of training
okay and going on a spiritual path pad
pad pad around India with a balsam yeah
i'd be pretty great cuz show business
isn't gonna make me want a murder well
exactly well i mean that it sounds like
it's a really great way to learn to be
patient about show business yeah it just
because you can transfer to the rest of
your life the thing that's a great thing
and I've learned from from that and also
yoga you know yoga is very much about
being present and you know I
come from like a like I said I play
football in high school and I do right I
came from I can push it go don't be a
[ __ ] you know like and that doesn't you
don't do that in work that right right
if you push too hard that's how you get
injured yes you know and you're supposed
to like you want to be bendy you want to
be bendy and you know if today you're
not that bendy it's okay yeah like
that's a big thing I've learned in the
letter the last three years I start
doing yoga because i had and chronic hip
and back pain and okay yeah i'm sitting
on planes and i had to really sort of i
couldn't run anymore mm-hmm and i can
run but just it's really hurts right so
you don't want to I don't want to say no
right out of it yeah whenever anything
hurts I never want to do it again I'm
always good that's one of my learned
skills it's but I like the idea of the
flashing steel just being sort of a
dialogue of how to how to like bring it
in to you the rest of your life right
but the study of itself like so did you
have did you what kind of sword fighting
is it is it's it's again it's it's very
it's very sort of the in the sword it's
very sort of choreographed because it's
it's your it's danger even with the
wooden ones yeah someone can get really
hurt okay so like when I study you know
karate you can spar you put on gloves
and a mouth padding and padding and you
can just start throwing punches and
kicks okay and you still getting kind of
get dinged up doing that bridges little
Bruce little bros yeah but you're
throwing a wooden sword in another
person that's are you throwing it into
their mouth cuz they won't shut it you
know i know i mean i don't mean actual
throwing right your-your-your swinging
the sword so you have to kind of do
these choreographed moves to practice
the the cuts and the blocks ok so to get
yours they need to be able to see them
coming so they can block them yeah and
you need you so as you get more advanced
and I have not become this advanced
pristine advanced like when Master Shin
Shimabukuro was alive and I saw him with
guys that have been studying with him
for 20 years right they would do some
amazing it looked like
samurai movie hey we're doing amazing
stuff but he's like very much you gotta
work your one right you're you're a year
into this Yuri is settled out yeah right
don't don't assume do that everyone's
gonna know what you're doing easy road
comic Wow your autobiography yes but
also then that is another thing too so
America were such a goal oriented
culture yeah so in when martial arts
first started there was white brown and
black belt okay the reason why in the
earth like a thousand years ago you had
a white belt that kept up your pants
okay you trained when it became brown
you've been in the dirt no wash your
belt oh there's a history of the belt
yeah so the belt then became black when
if when you'd been training outside for
that long and your belt was black that's
that was that's why you got a black belt
that's how that's a signet it was the
10,000 hours it was that kind of thing
exactly yeah so in olden times when
right it wasn't just them going hey
you're gonna need to give me twenty
seven dollars for a new belt yeah you've
already take these tests or whatever it
was right so that's where it really came
from okay the belt colors was the thing
that had to happen in America cuz
Americans were like you know I need a
sense i would like to graduate from
grade school yeah I'm okay this and I
need that and I need a gold star so that
was the other thing very supportive the
two of us if you have a green belt we
don't mean any harm oh it's all working
out for you just know that you're not a
real word okay no it's but I mean
it'sit's interesting studying all of
these several these different Japanese
martial arts you really see and i'm sure
you've gotten us to when you travel
around the world you really get to kind
of view American culture oh right
differently so if they look at the
martial art like if the Japanese are
looking at the martial arts and they're
like what do you have a yellow belt so
they're slightly confused and well
they're just like I mean I see what
you're doing yeah okay you're going to
have a
more of a measuring stick uh where we
just had you know dirt years betrayed to
hurt or whatever so so that was the
thing with with the samurai style not
again he had all these belt cues I mean
he he you you went up you didn't get
colored belts but you were just had a
cue a number you started then you
started at zero you had no number that
you were seven six five and he went all
the way up to one hell happened I don't
know what was that I don't know look at
that all right our lives are complete
you know he would test he wouldn't test
that often but that was the other thing
too when I studied karate it was like
you know you were tested almost every
six monster right you you know your sort
of include and that's that's not a bad
thing I'm not know it's encouraged to
look at where you're at and it's a new
set of eyes yeah there's nothing wrong
with that and it's good to sort of say I
liked tests in the sense that you know I
didn't like oh this belt didn't matter
to me but I like to sort of like goal of
this test is on this date down the road
you need to learn this little make sure
that the forms are right yeah I then got
a deadline I don't mind a deadline
deadline go right cuz I'm not gonna do
anything unless there's a deadline so
chop chop with the deadline we were just
like hey me we might do a podcast that
you know it never would have that right
how about we get some dates yeah very
hard on the line and then I guess I'll
get my [ __ ] together so so yeah but it
was he was very much about the patient
and if you weren't ready you'd get you
wouldn't pass and um and the etiquette
there was so much so much every martial
art has etiquette but it was really
emphasized how you bow you know how you
bow to the sword bow to the teacher bout
of the style hold your sword how you
carry yourself a I truly missed that all
right I need to go back to it because I
appreciate sort of because it's like the
Japanese have a tea ceremony mm-hmm
which is very methodical right and
here's the history of the Japanese tea
ceremonies this guy had offended a
samurai okay and the samurai was like
okay I'm coming by tomorrow
and we're gonna duel you oh this is this
always done it all yes so the guys the
samurai showed up he said sir could I
make you some tea and took forever to do
it right but did it so this is so
Japanese so perfectly so methodically
it's not about if Lee so beautifully it
sound about hurry up make me the tea
America style get it quick yeah it was
like do it right mm-hmm that by the end
of the tea ceremony the samurai was like
that was beautiful I forgive you there
you go you know you've you've regained
your honor and mine by making this
effort to make the tea yeah so now
that's a thing and it's it's not about
its it's about taking the time yeah and
so our lives are any modern life is
hectic yeah and whatever whoever's
listening out there whatever job or life
you have there's just some crazy
hecticness to it you know and right in
the multi tasking in the whole insanity
of it all you know anytime one's
listening to a podcast and working right
right now right now and and look we
obviously you and I both love technology
it's why we can sit here in your living
room and people all over the world can
hear us right but also technology it's
like Jesus it never rests right it's it
is literally the city that never sleeps
and it's my phone has been buzzing this
entire time right like so it never ends
whereas you know when we were younger
kids or whatever you had a home phone
and you left and then there was
voicemails when you got back and you if
if we didn't even have a answering
machine right Oh is he a little kid well
no we didn't have an answering machine
everyone got call waiting I was like 13
it was like oh my god right my parents
were like I don't need them yeah what am
I gonna do with that I wouldn't ever you
I'm all in at a time and there was a
busy signal there was a busy signal and
if you called and it was dinner time my
stepmother would just answer the phone
ago we're eating and then hang up you
without even finding out who called
who's calling it dinner time yes it was
like something out of a so I love the
idea of this sort of patience the idea
of this sort of taking taking time to
navel gaze and breathe and and really
learn how to do that so I learned from
this experience
so for starters a lot of the sword moves
are over your head so I can't do them in
my apartment unless I'm doing him from a
kneeling position ok so my apartment
complex has a roof deck so when I
started doing the samurai was like oh
god I'm gonna go on my roof yeah so what
I started from there is I used to keep
my phone on and I'd wake up and I tweet
now I turn my phone off when I go to bed
yeah when I wake up I don't turn it on
until I go on my roof I go my roof for a
half an hour i read i meditate and I
practice the sword ok yeah and that's
how I start my day that's a great and I
you know I turned my phone off when my
step mother died I don't have the phone
on at night because everyone dies at two
in the morning yeah and guess what still
gonna be dead in the morning I can't
[ __ ] I'm not gonna don't do a flight
to make sure i can get out it no I don't
want to get a jump on the grieving I
don't need to be sad for an extra six
hours it's not it's and and it maybe it
sounds callous but I'm like I'm gonna
get a good night's sleep and then I'm
gonna figure out what the [ __ ] the next
step is that's my that's my plan that's
what I and like so i will be awake for a
half hour 45 minutes or more before i
finally turn my phone on yeah and then
i'll look at the internet of my phone
but I don't read I don't watch TV I
don't get on the internet I don't do
anything i go up I go outside yeah so
anybody listening if you have any
outdoor whatever you got a patio you got
a backyard you got a roof deck you got
just fine and just be out in nature
first and I sworn it good ya in the
morning that's great and I was like a
great idea I get focused and then and
then you know especially like now like
the podcast festival is closed it's like
a week away yeah and it's crazy amount
of work and it's there's no there's no
nothing's blowing up it's just right but
this is what it is every year at this
time right it's there's just a thousand
things to do and think about and
organized and make sure that everybody
has answers to yeah yeah this and this
and this and so
so I if I if I just and also you know
this or anyone out there that's self
employed yeah your job never ends right
there's no there's no our you don't
punch out yeah it never stops so the
beauty of that is you know a Thursday
afternoon last week I went surfing in
the middle of the day I work right at
home for a couple hours and I was like
[ __ ] this I'm going outside and I
searched and came back and worked more
that's the beauty of the beauty but the
the downside is it never ends when
you're running around business there's
always something to do so i found i have
to really try to schedule myself yeah
and does want to make your own boundary
I have to make my own boundaries because
and that's one of the things i learned
from the samurai yeah is like they were
methodical men yeah they were
calligraphers then they had hobbies and
arts and we had other things they had
other things that they did and write the
tea ceremony and all this stuff that has
been been sort of created over centuries
but this was the samurai at the job yeah
that was that was the job does your job
you served the Shogun okay it one of the
Shogun's you you you were at the best of
that there was a miniseries I didn't see
it there are female samurai too oh yeah
yeah well that's kind of neat move on
yeah what's up with Lana and her
boyfriend yeah yeah yeah they got a
series now um so it's like yeah it so
they that was their work so they could
have the rest of their lives they could
read they could have art and they could
have music or they could sit around and
again you know raise sheep or have a
garden in their backyard or well that
was it the Japanese garden is another
thing that's like don't write write that
whole beautiful and again it's the same
it's about the precision of it it's
about taking the time to do it correctly
you know in Minneapolis uh when i worked
at Northern Sun merchandising hippie
t-shirt and poster shop still in
business I'm sure there's some lovely
anti-trump items if you would like to
get some effect any veggie oil /
stickers out there there is no doubt as
some sage that's been bundled
available so uh but when I bad spirits
out of your new place you guys so we we
have an 800 number and this guy would
call every couple of days and he was in
Stillwater prison in mini amp in
Minnesota and he he got the number
because there was an article about him
in an article about Northern Sun in the
paper next to each other and he was in
and he always called and he would always
joke that he was a political prisoner
and uh I was like I remember he had been
doing it for years when I started
working there and so I just stood there
like no don't worry bills fine don't
worry about Bill talk to Bill and so I
would talk to bill for like 20 minutes
or as long as they would let him use the
phone it was an 800 number so he could
dial out and he and and I remember him
telling I said well bill what did you do
and he said well they think they say I
didn't do it but they say I killed a
pizza delivery guy anyway I was like how
is that political and he's like oh
that's book anyway so he was very funny
and horrible but but he started the
reason there was an article is that he
had started the bonsai tree uh he had
started a bonsai class he'd studied
bonsai making bonsai trees and Ed's had
shared it with other inmates and so
there was this class that everybody
would make a wood could trim their
bonsai trees and there was nothing more
I thought it was fascinating that a guy
who was incarcerated would incarcerate a
tree like essentially bonsai making
bonsai you wrap this wire and shape it
in the way that you want it which is
what the prison system does right and
you trim it and you do this new krimpet
a new page it and you [ __ ] anyway so
went to visit him and because everybody
at Northern Sun had gone to visit bill
at some point and so me and my friend
Maureen dashed off and went to visit
Bill and Billie gave us each of bonsai
tree as a gift and I killed mine in a
week because their turns up it's a lot
of work as I Tracy but it was so
beautiful the tree was so beautiful I
felt really bad because of how much work
had been put into it and talk about a
precision kind of thing well I think
that's a
many of these sort of Eastern or
specifically Japanese things like the
the garden the raking of the garden
attending of the garden is a meditative
exercise nice to clear your mind of all
of the other stuff and that's why you
focus on the bonsai tree right a garden
or the sword or whatever so that because
even like for me meditating is kind of
hard my brain like I'm sure you and a
lot of comics our brains are kind of
always moving yeah and and that's not
just exclusive to being a comedian most
beautiful brains are kind of going all
over the place yeah and then me you know
just I've had a lot of [ __ ] I've got a
lot of demons to deal with and without
these things I would maybe go nuts so um
I mean I think about the fact that every
day you meditate for half an hour and
yet sometimes you're so full of rage
what would you be like you oh god that's
crazy imagine if I if I ate crappy food
and didn't work out and do yoga I'd be
dead I mean I would I would be dead
right or I'd in prison with Bill I get
possibly his ID tag I got a little lippy
with him politically she didn't do but
it was it was this thing where um cuz I
don't do any of that I do nothing I do a
whole lot of [ __ ] I do nothing my
meditative thing is I reread books that
I've read a hundred thousand times
before it is soothing I know how they
end turn sahota and and I like to I'd
like to reread so but I would like to do
something else you know it'd be nice to
get outside and it's I gotta tell you
the being outside thing is huge for me
um I was never a camping outdoor I just
wasn't you weren't that guy with you
surf that changed it for me cuz I'm lit
you're literally sub you know you're
immersed in nature right you know so
that Enders dolphins it swim by and fish
and and and where do you go surfing off
of like Santa Monica just down by Santa
Monica where I live cenomanian Venice
area Kenny I didn't even know you could
swim in that water even that's just fine
it has this idea that it's just like
like I don't know it's a giant oil slick
yeah houses syringes and
right is that where the plastic garbage
island is now it's the shard island it's
uh um so yeah I but I the thing I who
have you been surfing I've been surfing
for ten years okay so kind of comparable
yeah because 2004 with the samurai 2004
with this with the martial arts 2006
with the surfing surfing yeah I started
surfing I came back from my second
comedy tour to Afghanistan the second
one was in april of 06 i went there was
shame atosh and it was a pretty amazing
experience but it was also like we were
on a blackhawk that came under fire we
were in a firefight right um and then
the best insane it's insane yeah I never
nobody ever shot at me when I was in
Iraq but I was terrified that someone
was going to the Holt cuz we're in a war
zone yeah its net [ __ ] you know when
you go over there you can watch it on
the movie and the movies are a CNN or an
embedded reporter but until you're
sitting on a blackhawk and there's 260
caliber machine guns pointed out the
window and they're firing and there yeah
and they were lighting guys up and and
they deployed countermeasures and you
know when that stuff happens and then
they took us into an operating theater
in at Bagram and they were prepping they
were there was one a 13 year old Afghan
boy who got hit with an IED and so his
they were putting is like jaw and face
back together so I saw the exposed bone
of a 13 year old boys jaw Jesus and then
there was a nine-year-old boy that got
was playing in a minefield because it's
the most heavily mined country in the
world because of the Russians Rai the
80s and and nobody police's their
breaths when it comes to mind their ass
hats take your minds with you when you
leave no [ __ ] know so where'd the
Soviet Union wasn't really a I don't
even think the US did in Korea or
Vietnam no right now just plant them and
then take off yeah I we're done we're
done having our war we living sorry good
luck yeah third world country right
Jesus so yeah and then they were
prepping a nine-year-old boy for brain
surge
me and um I got back and so there's the
second time I'd been to Afghanistan and
I just got back and I was just kind of
out of it the first time in 04 I went I
was kind of out of it this time I I went
on this tour like I know what I'm doing
I'm not freaked out yeah and then that
happened towards the end of the tour and
well it's it all we fed kids through
barbed wire and yes so I got back and
was just kind of out of it and in April
27th 2006 was the day we got in the
firefight mm-hmm and we deployed flares
which our countermeasures and I found
out later that's too countermeasures to
distract a rocket so you've been
targeted and there's a rocket right so
the rocket will then chase the Flair vs
the heat signature from the melody
nurtured in yeah yeah so holy crap I was
like oh we almost got blown out of the
sky ok cool yeah yeah I'm done yeah and
so I just was like I just sort of
checked out and my buddy Walker you all
who does the AV for pod fest he had gone
back to college mm-hmm and was like am
graduating I want to give myself a
present what you think we take surf
lessons I was like let's do it all right
so we took surf lessons and then that
whole summer of 06 that's kind of I just
that's all I did was serve because I
just and we started editing laughs gana
Stan the documentary i did about it
which is available in comedy film nerds
we download you guys or hard copy if you
like just dump oh just all of the money
VDC it's a pay what you think it's very
download but don't be J can put a penny
right um five bucks come on ten bucks
that's what my Horcruxes on comedy is
it's genlux you know why cuz we're not
Louis CK that's why I don't have a
hundred thousand fans i got 3,000 yeah
oh that's like 10 bucks it'll be fun for
two bucks oh yeah I have bills yeah my
car is 240,000 miles on um so yeah I got
back and just started got it I got into
surfing and so just everyday essentially
for the summer of two thousand six yeah
because it's the only thing to you go
out there and I don't care how good of
an athlete here you are you are gonna
get your ass
handed to you all right in in waves that
are knee-high like it is a really
chanted thing right so not even tall
huge waves and then there were days we
went out when it was way too big and we
didn't know what we were doing and we
just got eight and then you lived yeah
god like oh okay so yeah we ice got into
surfing and then when I finally started
I got a different a better bigger
thicker bored and started to pop up and
ride waves and I remember by the end of
the summer I was sitting on the beach
with a couple surf buddies and I was
like after we just finished and I was
like I get it and they go what I go guys
that just check out the ice you have a
backpack on a surfboard right they just
I get it I go that's all I want to do
that's what I want to do is this mm-hmm
what made you not do it because my
brother is whoever the fill is like I'm
gonna get a top to my pickup truck and
I'm just gonna go fly fish until i die
and i think it was i think it was like
well i feel i owned a house at the time
and I was like well how my God my bills
like right how am I gonna you know and
am I ready to just completely like check
out of society right and so no and then
I'm gonna regrouped I kind of regrouped
and like let's make this film and then I
started going on and then like a year or
so later like 08 started going on the
road more again and then podcasting
started and then right now I'm I'm this
like you're that guy I'm this podcasting
businessman but there's it's still
especially on the days that are long and
frustration frustrating and don't pay
that well as when I still go okay I just
want to learn where we going brazil was
it gonna happen wherever you just live
up right where could i live like if
someone were to say to me right now
mm-hmm hey Graham here's a job you know
whatever working for the surfrider down
in Brazil and you just help educate kids
and there's money and a place to live
right and tuition or you know you know
there isn't a boatload of money but you
could go surfing every day if you wanted
to life is your bills are paid you got
money for food and a couple little fun
things in this health care yeah I'd be
like bye yeah
enough and and when that happens i don't
know if i'll tell anybody about it i
think im just gonna drift off as people
i haven't seen grab let's check his
twitter feed oh nothing nothing and he's
done yeah he's off the grade you guys I
every time and I've said it before every
time we go to Arkansas there's Andy owns
an acre next to his dad's property as
dads widows that there now and she got
there six acres in the middle of this
National Forest right it's gorgeous it's
one of the most beautiful place I've
ever seen in the world and I have
genuinely I've been to some amazing
losses and it's in Arkansas but all the
people that I've met in Arkansas as far
as I could tell her hiding rooms yeah
here off the grid I'm there there they
don't have regular jobs and I live here
in Los Angeles where nobody has any job
right everyone's consistently making up
job I saw something on facebook there's
a guy and silverlake who will walk you
he's not a dog walker he's a people
walker and you pay him 15 bucks and
he'll walk around with you he's gonna be
a billionaire I'm billion air and uh
only if he only I gotta let go of just
like ethics and just start some just
full-on flim-flam [ __ ] like I'm
gonna protect your dog soul after you
die or whatever like I don't I don't I
was thinking about I have a lot of
friends who have like service animals
and their emotional service animals
right and I was thinking about the
commitment some of those dogs not all
dogs and if you're hearing this it's not
about you how about that uh but maybe it
is think about because I was I went to
visit my in-laws Andy has two moms they
live upstate in the Central Valley and
we go to visit they have these two
little dogs that one's like a pound dog
and the other one they just found it
right and so and then they have a cat
that they just found like the Andy's
family doesn't buy animals they just
have animals animals show up and they're
like an animal was gonna die unless we
put can fix it and so I got a fair now
we have a dog now I have an iguana which
is why we have an iguana and iguana just
showed up here uh Andy was at work and a
guy bought three equal
impulse bought three iguanas where does
this happen the space station uh sony
playstation in the in the 25 years ago
and andy was like you can't have three
ago they grow to be like three four feet
long and I guys like oh yeah it's
somebody told me that and so does
anybody wanna guana and so and he was
like i'll take it at guana and some
other guy took an iguana those two guys
they killed durg juana's within months
and andy is hannahs iguana for 23 years
and I'm iguanas 23 years old yes and
hilariously when I met Andy 15 years ago
or whatever it is now I said how old see
iguana and he told me and he goes about
10-12 and I said how long do guano's led
they said 15-20 years and then a couple
years ago I was like how long do iguanas
like it's like 25-30 years and I'm like
it keeps changing no 60 70 years wrote
in for the duration which is iguana but
um now is the iguana in the will you
guys my ass before right right who gets
he at guana we got we're gonna have to
leave him to Mike Rick Berg microwave
for gloves the iguana and he has a weird
pet too he's got a peg so that lives in
his backyard goddammit well like blocks
from here the time I think I'm a winged
bird you meet someone who has a pet pig
is 300 pounds yeah and and he hasn't
eaten any of it like he hasn't even you
know that old joke joke about the pot of
three legged pick your event oh it's
essentially about us traveling salesman
who meets a farmer that has a
three-legged pig in the farmer the the
salesman's like how'd your pickle is its
leg and the farmers like well you know
this pig saved our lives it you know
came and woke us up when the house was
on fire or some damn thing and there's
like three of them cuz it's a joke right
and then finally else was like did they
lose the did he lose it in the house
fire is like no or did he lose it when
he pushed you out of the way the tractor
know and finally he's like how did he
lose a leg and the farmer goes we can't
eat a pig like that all at once he's
like what a dick and it's a joke joke so
I don't know why I care about that big
feelings is the pig is it real
oh definitely picked picked this aside
in a joke joke and dead defendant great
emotional again again these farmers
daughters now hold on now they're not
being treated well it doesn't seem fair
and those those women need to commit to
their own lives instead of looking for
some salesman at this bartender that
these three ethnic men walk do seems
super judgment anyway so Abby's moms
have these two dogs and their adorable
dogs and they are entirely [ __ ] dogs
they're just dumped you throw things
they bring them back to you they
interrupt your life they want to be pet
they bark a little so one of them barks
too much and um that's all I dogs do is
interrupt your life they're super
supportive there's never annoying that
is a dog that is a beautiful dog
experience I love dogs with the power of
the Sun and his step on Fran is just she
loves those dogs they all they both
Andy's mom loves the cat but they both
love all the animals right but Fran is
like I love the dog I love the dog oh
the dog is acting up I yell at the doc
stop doing that dog and instead of this
is my emotional support vehicle right
where uh just people who are like you
could just picture they shake these some
of these service animals that I've met
they shake so bad that you're like okay
so late at night you're just crying with
this dog in your hands right and that in
the weight of the world is on that
[ __ ] dog I don't know if it's true or
if it's just I just feel bad sometimes
it's not fair to the dog it doesn't much
like the pig in the joke I have made up
a fictional life for somebody else's dog
or just like I was at some I was at some
um it was a coffee shop and it was a dog
in a service vest and the dog so I saw a
kid go up to the dog and then the kid
was like can I pet the dog and the woman
goes no he bites and I was like hey
bites cuz he's got all of your emotions
and his own and
i I've anthropomorphize the dog too much
obviously I mean I'm I've gone I've lost
my [ __ ] I'm so sorry I've derailed the
door force what's your favorite sword
movie let's do it oh I don't I was I
want to actually more about surfing a
little bit because you've obviously 10
years now you can stand up oh yeah I sir
I mean it's like I served two three
times a week and it's a part of my life
right it has like when I in the winter
if I'm on the road a lot I'll be like I
haven't surfed in two weeks and I'm like
it's it hurt it affects my mood right
you know um it's just gotta be a fight
with the waves the whole time though
right let me get out there and tell you
it's the conditions you go out in and
you know I'd sort of there's certain
breaks I go and I sort of know where I'm
around time and just to tide I know time
and space and I bend it so that I think
oh interesting time travelers wife
Graham Elwood yeah it should be so much
more wealthy there's no reason I'm
struggling to pay my bills if I can
exactly um so yeah it's it's uh you know
there's and there's there's surf web
sites that have served cams and reports
and the technology is fantastic now like
how they did it in the 50s just like you
went outside when we're all right you
know then giant wave comes you have no
idea right um so now you can they
predict the week and you can be like ooh
Thursday and you know when it's gonna be
low tide and okay it's time to go and
it's it's glow tights the best time tis
late cuz then you can get out pass some
sort of it's not about waiting it's not
about getting out past the point so much
it's it's uh wipes your caused by the
oceans floor Jackie so I think caused by
the oceans floor yes so on a wave a
storm is this was the moon what the why
was misled so a storm will happen way
out in the middle of the ocean that
sends a rippling effect to the waves
okay so if there's
if you've ever been in like a doc yeah
so it has to be deep for the boats yes
so there's not big there's not rolling
waves typically in there unless there's
like a giant storm right there right so
they just kind of come in and kind of
hit the yeah the whatever this that was
there right um where is a good surf
break you want sort of a grade to go
from deep slowly up to shallow those are
the wave the wave is kind of coming and
then when it hits the floor of the ocean
that's when it starts to make the like
da the cook curly-q curly-q the crash
the barrel or depressed whatever you
want to come on doesn't always
necessarily barrel so then when that's
writing then you want to be on what's
called a shoulder or a corner okay if
the wave all breaks at the same time
yeah there's nothing for you to ride
okay you want to be at the edge of the
wave so it's sort of pushing behind you
okay is that make sense yeah yeah I
think so cuz that's how the curlicue
works if it pushes you into the middle
of it to some extent or it pushes you
off to the edge of it sure yeah again
it's so specific to the direction of the
waves and then which way you're pointed
which way you're pointed on your board
but also the the tide and and the bottom
of the floor at that specific break so
like though that you'll go to a website
and will be that like there's that
there's a swell coming from the
southwest okay so any south west facing
beaches are going to get these waves
okay if you're a West or north facing
Beach you might not get it because uh
the land faces both west and north like
the the coastline sure ya like like
Santa Monica Bay to outface due west it
faces south west okay so if you get down
into like orange county yeah the
coastline kind of straightens out and it
faces more due west okay and there's
some peaks or points where you could
have an almost a north-facing if like a
jetty comes out yeah then on the right
side of it it will face sort of north
and on the left side it will face sort
of south okay so if the wave hits the
point of that jetty mm-hmm then you're
going to have a right or left break
coming off of either side of that jetty
okay that makes sense yeah i wish i had
some visual aids here
no no well um it makes sense I don't
know how you would play how are you how
would you surf a point so yeah so I'll
give you a great example of a point so
we're Sunset Boulevard hits the PCH the
pacific coast highway there okay right
there okay and it isn't it is a jetty so
the wave hits it and it hits the so the
wave hits the point how do I describe
this so the left side of the wave hits
the point okay so then it makes the wave
break to the right ok so you yep no
matter what you do you have to go right
on this wave ok because to your left is
white water it's already broken ok till
your right is the it's just bubbles it's
just well it's starting to curve like if
you've ever gone online and anybody
listening go online and just search surf
videos ok and type in literally like
right point break ok and you'll see what
I'm talking about so like the the wave
will break to the right so you have to
be on your board so when you're paddling
for that wave your sort of aiming the
nose to the right a little bit cuz you
can tell which way it will break yeah
well especially if you know that break
ok like that's a very specific break
where you know that wave is gonna break
it's always gonna bring almost always
there are some left that yam in there
but it's almost always rights ok so you
know that going in I'm go there you go
ok so that's how you know that you're
like so I'm not gonna want to bear left
hardly at all if ya if ever you can but
there's cuz the best wave is when you
ride across the face of it as it's
breaking mm-hmm that's the most amazing
thing you can ever do because you go up
to like the top the lip of the way out
you come back down across the face
you've got your hand on the wave as
you're going through the water yeah it's
like hand on glass it's the it's it's
the most amazing I've played all
different kinds of sports I've skied
I've snowboarded got all this thing
nothing in my opinion as fun as that
you're writing the pulse of the earth
right wow it's and you're just on a
board yeah you don't need to be towed in
you don't need a ski lift you don't need
any of this other craziness right you
just paddle out there with the strength
of your own arms yep and then you
pop up and then you're riding this wave
and there's nothing like it when you
catch it perfectly how long does it last
it depends on it's not long it's like 10
seconds yeah some so less and how many
waves can you catch when you go out it
really depends it's so exhausting right
i mean do you go for like a couple hours
yeah you go I mean I'll yeah if you'll
try to catch as ready as you can yeah
okay and you'll and you might get what
half a dozen really depends on the day
and what's going on and like I went out
the other day and it was the tide was
coming up so it was harder so I
literally only caught two waves in like
an hour but I've gone out with every
moment every moment it's like stand-up
comedy in the sense that there's 23
hours in the day where you're there
sleeping or flying or hustling gigs or
blah blah blah and then that 30 or 45
minutes you're on stage is if the crowd
is good is gold yeah yeah but it's such
a small moment of the actual day that
you're an actual comedian right right
the rest of its admin yeah exactly
exactly all right or travel and whatever
yeah so it's like that was surfing your
your but you're you know you're in the
ocean you're sitting on a board you know
I've seen dolphins crest 10 feet from me
I've seen ya seals and just screwed up
playing like right next to you is
actually just riding the same way by
riding the wave before you or I've had a
dolphin go under my board it was the
most amazing thing a little like oh oh
whoa oh but it's um they have a really
good sense of distance so yeah he didn't
knock you over right up you know what
he's doing they're pretty good surfers
dolphins as it turns out you come in for
them yeah they didn't pick it up in
their 30s so Graham Elwood le pop fest
is this weekend so um 21st September
23rd through the 25th 23rd to 25th and
it's at the sofitel over in hollyweird
off of la cienega and Beverly Boulevard
and what's the website the website is LA
pod fest com there's not a concern
there's still tickets the Saturday
passes our think sold out there's still
three day passes there's Friday and
Sunday passes and if you can't make it
to LA you can watch the whole thing well
that's right there's a live streaming
thing of the whole damn thing is yes the
whole weekend and we record
everything an archived it for 30 days so
anything you missed you can watch you
have a month to watch everything and the
podcast doesn't don't like last year i
got a check yeah the show's get paid the
show's get paid if you use their coat
yeah right and so every show has a code
like how many film what's comedy film
nerds cosi FN oddly enough so if you do
that you save five dollars so the stream
normally costs 25 bucks for the whole 30
days right it normally costs 25 bucks
for the whole 30 days use coupon code
CFN you save five dollars and that's
funny that's 20 and that's how we get
pay too yeah seven bucks every time
somebody uses that coupon code okay so
then it's a kick back to the shows it's
an pay the artists and awesome and it's
a rep share and you're supporting
podcasting you're supporting this
awesome festival um and super fun it's a
blast right and if you can cut gonna go
go come to it because it's it's three
days of not having to explain to anybody
what a podcast oh my god so true what
channel is it uh don't worry you
download it Oh what time is it hard
whenever you want how do I get it oh my
god it could be less hard do you have an
iPhone yeah then you have the app no
yeah you to pull out your phone I've
done this you have a computer yeah uh
any sort of computer anything at all it
doesn't matter it's even even your
shitty computer yeah so it's at Graham
Elwood is your it's graham cracker so
Graham Elwood and for Twitter and
Instagram and then County film nerds is
your podcast and I've been on it before
and it's good times and this has been a
great up sighs Jackie thank you so much
for taking time to do it Rangers you
know the rule out there take care of
each other I had my hat my hat they're
dancing around my hat I hat my hat my
hat well what do you think of that if it
looks like a Mexican Hat dance and it
sounds like a Mexican Hat dance it's
most likely a mexican hackett so take up
your head and let stand yay oh my god we
why don't we just call that at the end
of the show